infiltrated into the Kuts
itself just this morning it's now it's
now early evening in Israel right now
but Elon Musk uh is now in southern
Israel visiting some of uh the the
communities that
were decimated I don't know another word
for it uh and here's video we're going
to show you about 30 seconds this is uh
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu touring some of those
communities with Elon Musk last night
some of them returned home not home yet
but they returned to Israel and most of
them were kidna from the houses here is
when the terrorists infiltrated into the
kibuts
itself this is the
house on his way back you notice several
terrorists that were right over
here it's uh
it's a symboling the boots you have kids
inside mothers and the fathers run
around with it but it's holding
shells specifically of
AAS that was used here in order to
protect the
people the idea now that we're all kind
of coming around to that societies
Western societies especially are going
to have to make some hard decisions
relative to the people that are in their
societies again some of them legally
some of them illegally
uh comes right up against what just
happened in Israel a month or was it now
almost two months ago what will Western
societies tolerate do we tolerate not
having borders and letting people come
in and rape our women and kill our
children and burn down whole communities
and kill innocent people and all of
those things and cause you know massive
upheaval and take hostages and
everything else will we tolerate that or
will we actually be brave enough to do
the right thing not just say we're going
to do the right thing not just say we
have principles but actually do
something in the in the face of evil now
there's another layer of this that I
think is particularly important as it
relates to Elon Musk which is that if it
was not for Elon defending free speech
in this last year since he bought
Twitter SLX uh it would be very hard to
know what was going on in the world
right now because Elon has opened it up
so that when they show you videos of
what actually happened in Israel or when
you see some of the riots that are
happening across Europe right now and
the and the calls for genocide and
everything else those are things that
obviously would have been censored more
and are being censored more on the other
platforms like YouTube like Facebook etc
etc so the fact that Elon Musk the
number one guy really in the world right
now defending all of our ability to
communicate freely over these pipes over
these magical wires uh that he is going
there uh I think sends a real signal to
people it also sends a signal to the
people who think that either you know
the sort of crazy people who whose
brains have been broken by Tik Tok and
everything else who thinks who think
that Israel made all of this up or
there's no evidence of it or anything
else